what do we mean by the transpose of a
matrix to find the transpose of a matrix
we simply interchange its rows and
columns yes that gives us its transpose
let's try out an example this is matrix
a it has two rows and two columns we
need to find the transpose of this
matrix it is written as a with T as a
superscript what will this be equal to
we need to interchange the rows and
columns the first row becomes the first
column the first row is 1/4 so the first
column of the transpose will be 1/4 the
first row became the first column and
the second row of the matrix will become
the second column of its transpose the
second row is minus 2/3 so the second
column of the transpose will be minus
2/3 the rows of the matrix become the
columns of its transpose or we can also
say that the columns of the matrix
become the rows of its transpose column
1 became Row 1 and column two became Row
2 but students often get confused at
this point so here's a good way to
remember transpose assume that there are
4 cement bags 2 on top of the other to
the top two bags weigh one kilogram and
four kilograms and the bottom to weigh 2
kilograms and 3 kilograms let's say we
put a box underneath it if we pushed the
first row the 4 kilo bag will fall here
and on pushing the 1 kilo bag it will
land on the 4 kilo bag now let's push
the bags in the second row towards the
right the 3 kilo bag will fall here and
the 2 kilo bag will fall on top of it
this is the transpose of this matrix the
first row became the first column and
the second row became the second column
so this was just one of the ways to
understand transpose of a matrix
okay so here's matrix B I want you to
try finding the transpose of matrix B
so the first row will become the first
column of the transpose the first row is
1 2 minus 1 1 2 minus 1 will be the
first column of B transpose the second
row 3 0 4 will become the second column
of the transpose 3 0 4 that's B
transpose the rows and the columns were
interchanged if we are using a cement
bag approach this is how it will look
the first row falls to become the first
column and the second row Falls to
become the second column what is the
order of matrix B it has two rows and
three columns its order will be 2 by 3
and B transpose has 3 rows and 2 columns
3 by 2 the order is also reversed 2 by 3
becomes 3 by 2 if the matrix is of order
3 by 4 then its transpose will be of the
order 4 by 3 we will look at more
examples over the next few sessions